well of course recently veteran new
yorker writer jeffrey toobin was fired
from his job after an incident
where uh well apparently he was caught
masturbating during a work zoom meeting
tuban claimed it was an accident he
didn't realize people could still see
him on camera
well this story was a real cautionary
tale and it's nice to see zoom is trying
to address this problem
head-on in their latest ad
one of our most popular features is our
zoom virtual
backgrounds they're fun while also
providing users with a sense of privacy
well some recent events have made us
consider other ways we can make zoom
more
discrete that's why we're introducing
new
zoom virtual foregrounds virtual
foregrounds provide just enough privacy
to allow you to conduct your own
business without disrupting others
so you won't attract any unwanted
attention while you
look at your phone check on your kids
or whatever choose from a variety of
discreet foregrounds like
important business birthday celebration
jewish cats meat lovers foreground
and not masturbating sign they're
suitable for
any professional environment so let's
look at the third quarter projections in
the south asian market
craig do you have that data is crunching
the numbers
and are great for socially distanced get
togethers
[Music]
zoom virtual foregrounds now only god
can judge you